if i could summarize this lawsuit in one
sentence dan balzerian got sued for
being a spoiled rich kid
basically the guy's suing him for
wrongful termination and in this lawsuit
he alleges that dan fired him because he
wouldn't approve a bunch of his business
expenses
uh and so it just turned into a pissing
match and uh you know
man baby dan balzerian decided to fire
him but not before he accused the guy
of being on drugs and quote acting
strange you heard that right dan
balzerian is officially trying to take
the high ground
on drugs uh so the details of this case
i'll go through real quick because i
know we covered it a little bit
yesterday but as a quick disclaimer
obviously everything in
here is an allegation and everything i
say about it will be my opinion but
what's really relevant here are not only
his insane expenditures like paying for
100
000 flight to london or like buying a
paintball field for 75k and expecting
investors and the company to foot the
bill it's that when a guy who's working
for the company flags these expenses and
refuses to approve them
allegedly dan just fired the guy problem
solved but that's not all
in this lawsuit we see some really
creative accounting going on
where dan balzerian's company ignite is
trying to classify
ppp loans as income aka you know like
that small business loan you can apply
for from the government for covert
relief
yeah ignite was trying to mark that as
income in order to balance their budget
sheet now i'm no cpa but you can't mark
a
debt alone as income and the only reason
you would is to look good in the eyes of
investors
this i guess was to offset some of dan
bilzerian's 800
000 worth of personal spending that's
not me saying it by the way apparently
his auditing company
flagged 800 000 worth of stuff that
seemed to be quote
personal in nature but literally none of
this stuff would have come out if dan
blizzarian would have just not fired him
and not accused the guy of taking drugs
but he couldn't keep his mouth shut
because he was pissed off that the guy
wouldn't approve
wouldn't approve his spending it's
literally insane
it's like a giant tantrum blown up into
a lawsuit
and the last big thing that i didn't
cover last time is that apparently dan
bilzerian was told
by this employee that he shouldn't be
renting out that 2.4 million dollar a
year house anymore because
why do you really need some super mega
party mansion
when during cove and you're not going to
go to throw parties to which dan
balzerian threw a little fit
and said i'm going to be doing some
summer pool parties and will utilize the
house
yes you heard that right dan bilzerian
can't cut 2.4 million dollars in
expenses from this bloated company
because he needs his summer pool parties
i bring all this up for a couple of
reasons
for one it turns out the image of dan as
some
alpha self-made poker star is
hilariously inaccurate he's just the
trust fund rich kid
and secondly because it turns out you
and i are picking up the tab on
bulsarian's frivolous spending
see remember that ppp loan valzarian
applied for yeah
it turns out he got 1.2 million
dollars in government assistance now you
might be saying yourself well yeah he's
going to pay that back it's a loan
but ignite just applied for loan
forgiveness and if they get that it
officially means that
you and i are footing the bill for
over-hyped la
pool parties uh literally insane anyway
that's all i wanted to say
the lawsuit will be linked below if you
want to take a look for yourself
see ya oh danny boy
the feds the feds are calling
[Music]
they want to know
where you have run off to
all the money's gone
and they want to know where you have put
it
[Music]
is it in the ping pong table
or the brand new pool you bought
don't bluff billionaires that's
something i learned like early on